[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jay billis espn college basketball
analyst and uh
popular analyst at that joining us on
the program uh emotional weekend there
what did you expect was going to happen
uh with the final game there with coach
k at cameron
i didn't know um
as you
said there was an emotional element to
it that none of us could predict
you know how we'd feel and even though
we knew this was coming uh since last
spring
uh the finality of it and the fact that
there was so much it was like a royal
wedding in a way i mean there was so
much pomp and circumstance around it the
the media coverage i mean the the the
media camped out there was uh was
incredible
uh so it was kind of an odd feeling and
then having all the former players down
there before the game uh one it was
really cool to see everybody but um it
was just it was so different than
anything uh i've ever been through
before
uh but it was it was there were parts of
it that were incredibly cool you know
you just wonder is it going to impact
the game and i don't know honestly i
don't know whether it did or didn't i
mean before that before the game
everybody talked about the emotion it's
going to be this great weight on the
players and all that
uh but i think i had said if duke wins
everybody's going to say they rode the
wave of emotion to a victory if they
lose they're going to say it was a huge
distraction and a reason they lost all
that stuff's just a
sort of an excuse or rationalization
it may have been a factor but at the end
of the day you have to play and carolina
was just better if i would have said to
you in 1985
we're going to get to this point with
coach k where we might be celebrating
him as the greatest college basketball
coach of all time what would you have
thought
i mean i wouldn't have disputed it but
it's certainly hard to imagine that
anyone could stick around somewhere 40
plus years and have this kind of success
i mean
when my my class
which included johnny dawkins mark
gallery david henderson and tommy amaker
was the next year
when that group left um there was no
no guarantee they'd ever have a team
that good i mean we won 37 games that
last year we were there and that was a
record
an all-time record and uh what it took
till 2012 until kentucky won 38 to beat
that uh so and and coach k had two or
three 37 win teams after that
and final fours and national
championships i mean a coach makes one
final four it's a career maker and he's
made 12 and has a chance for another one
this year that that that just
you know that's where when i was always
really sensitive growing up in los
angeles to the john wooden discussion of
the greatest of all time that people
would try to take wooden down a peg by
saying well they played in the west and
it was easy to get through the west and
uh he had al cinder and walton well that
was true i mean he won five titles while
a cinder and walton he won five without
him
and uh but but coach k did it at uh at
the highest level for longer like wooden
won 10 in 12 years which will never
happen again
to say it's extraordinary as an
understatement
but
the argument for coach k against wooden
is that he did it for 40 years
you know as number one and all these
different things did it in the
television and internet uh era when
there were so many changes going on
uh it's really really remarkable i'm not
sure we'll ever see his like again in
that regard i was wondering about this
you go back to johnny dawkins which to
me was sort of that transformational
recruit that coach k got and then he
convinced leightoner leightoner's mom to
not go to north carolina and go to duke
grant hill convincing him and his father
not to go to north i mean
north carolina was going to get
leightoner and hill
and
you know so if you look at those three
would you is that correct though that
that was sort of what was happening at
the time that johnny i think was a a big
difference maker coming in and then the
fact that he talked leitner and uh grand
hill out of going to north carolina
yeah that was a the big turning point
johnny dawkins is the most important
player to ever play at duke it's
certainly under coach king that that
but for johnny dawkins i'm not sure this
honestly this happens maybe it does but
i'm not sure it does uh the the key guy
though before leightoner and and hill
in the duke versus north carolina
recruiting battle was danny fairy uh
danny fairy was a high school senior in
1985 and carolina was all over him
and back then when carolina recruited
you you went
and duke got ferry as the number one
number one player in the country and
that was when the tide started to shift
and it became a fair fight in recruiting
and and duke could get a player that
carolina wanted
uh so that was the one and ferry you
know ferry went to three final fours
uh during his period there was national
player of the year and one of the best
college players frankly i ever saw
um so that was the guy that i think
greased the skids for
you know the duke versus carolina
recruiting battles and and the truth is
dan
duke in north carolina recruited the
same guys and still do
and uh and i always thought it was funny
like
uh duke recruited i was a grad assistant
when duke was recruiting the heck out of
eric montross
and he chose carolina and carolina
recruited the heck out of leightoner and
hurley and all that
and carolina fans hated leitner and
hurley and duke fans hated montross who
may be the nicest person that's ever
lived and you're going do you guys
realize that they made a different
decision you would have put statues up
of the the guys you claim you hate but
on both sides it just they both both
schools recruit unbelievable guys
and there's not a better person on the
planet than hubert davis
um and if he had gone to duke uh he'd be
a duke icon and they'd they'd tout him
but uh you know he went to carolina so
they don't they don't care for him it's
just that that's part of the rivalry i
guess
but i look back on leitner and i know
leighton was so important to the program
but did he also create sort of that us
against the rest of the world mentality
by his style of play his personality
yeah that that probably started with
ferry a little bit and fairy and quinn
snyder kind of brought
uh laitner up and they were pretty hard
on him uh when he was a freshman
and uh and later had unbelievably tough
skin he's probably you know in addition
to
being arguably the best player ever at
duke he was the best competitor that's
ever played there
that dude was unbelievable and i don't
remember him dan ever getting outplayed
whether it was shaquille o'neal or
whomever
o'neil may have been a better player but
he did not play leighton i don't
remember anybody ever doing that and
later like i used to play tennis with
leightoner and you know he played ping
pong and you know ridiculously
competitive in those things and people
don't believe this but it's true
leightoner at 6 10 6 11 whatever he was
could get in a handstand and walk on his
hands from one baseline to the other
uh he was an extraordinary athlete not
in the run and jump sense he was a good
athlete but but an extraordinary athlete
and the things that he could that the
different things he was capable of doing
like when you and i were kids
athlete meant could do it could play a
lot of different sports and do a lot of
different things now it means run and
jump
uh but but leightoner was an
extraordinary athlete in that way he's
jay bilas espn college basketball
analyst did it feel like the end of an
era on saturday
yeah not just coach k but i'm talking
about college basketball
yeah uh but but we've i've felt that
before you know when bob knight uh left
indiana or when dean smith retired or
when i was a kid when wooden retired at
the final four in 1975
uh you felt like oh boy it's never going
to be the same and it is never going to
be the same
but but in one part there's there's
sadness because
he's leaving
but on the other part it it's exciting
it's exciting for the next chapter for
him and his family but it's also
exciting for the game too because there
are other people that are going to step
in
so i'm not worried about the game
just like i wasn't worried about it when
one and done or worried about it when
we've had the three-point line came in
or other changes
um the game will be the game will be
just fine
but uh but he let
bob knight said this about henry iva i
think when he went in the hall of fame
of all the shadows cast in the game his
is the longest and i kind of feel that
way about coach k that that the shadow
he he's cast in this game
is the longest there's ever been there
have been some pretty long ones with
dean smith and bob knight and pete
newell you name it all the great coaches
and the current guys now like with
you know bayheim and izzo and calipari
and all these guys we've had some iconic
coaches but
one thing that is changing is is
you know now that the the game it's been
professional for a long time but now
that it's really professional with the
players able to to
monetize their their talent
and the transfer portal you know
now the coaches are not uh supreme like
they were in the past
they they have to change the way they do
business
and so you know we're going to see a
little bit of change in that we may not
have the super powerful
kind of royalty type coaches like we've
had
it it may become a little more
professional in that regard too
great to talk to you again jay we'll uh
talk to you tournament time thanks for
joining us as always
thanks for having me good to be with you
that's jay bilas espn college basketball
analyst